till till you explain already a little
bit um you know where will you still
have faith in of what you suggest okay
let's put our energy in X Y its morals
its ethics its philosophy it's humanism
this religion is first of people who
good souls it's it's all of this package
and of course at times many people think
this is theoretical this is dreamers a
professor that we will have he passed
away was a great meant that I was very
lucky to have great mentors of
philosopher of thinkers underwater from
other country he told me 20 30 years ago
he was he was the mind behind the human
indicators that the UN has developed not
measuring our progress on the biography
GMP so he took me for in de and Tilly we
vanish you have to know that there are
the good and leave us so whenever you
face evil close your eyes and keep
counting how many good songs around you
and that gives you the power to continue
and he's very very nice so I don't think
I'm naive to think that were no longer
going to have the evil slavers are going
to be there all over around us all of us
and almost there Eva's when they are
with greed for politics for power for
money and from what i have been noticing
even in Libya after the Revolution I
think I'm I'm offensive incredible with
power and politics thus to be all and
then this point they have to say I'm
sorry two men when that doesn't mean
that many women are not also affected by
but because the world is dominated by
men
we're everywhere they are responsible
for this global hairs and this this is
why in my opinion now as a Libyan I will
never leave again Libya to be control me
or other women of necessarily mean only
by men not because I hate men but I'm
sorry they have proven x and x and x and
then sorry to say also that I'm deleting
from my list of my old friends were in
top position many names because once
they reach positions of power other they
are other human beings are other
creatures so again philosophically
speaking you wonder how they were so
good at solving the opposition because
now what we're facing in everywhere the
intellectuals have to be blames the
thinkers have to be blames the
opposition's have to be blames because
in my opinion there's times there are
many floated eagles in other ways people
are going to dreaming up there and the
reality down there is different okay and
and in this regard I think and there's
this debate is going on in the airport
dating for the last 45 years
intellectual have been too much employed
in there on closed circles with the
language that the lay people are not
understanding exactly happening Olivia
today to deliver starving last week
lipid went in the street talking about
we are starving imagine a country of 6
million people with all the oil wealth
with all the oil that everybody's be
coming becoming a millionaire corruption
has tripled maybe from the time of even
the old regime and solid to say that so
I think it's a long journey I don't know
the international organization that the
national community I'm sorry I make
hell even exactly saying that I am tired
of saying you and ass you and us now is
a stupid because you are also singing
with us